[Music]
we're gonna take you through a short
journey in the next 50 minutes so sit
back and relax in these beautifully
comfortable chairs and this is going to
start with a background on don't foods
and how this hundred-year-old
manufacturing company became a global
leader in the bakery industry and we're
gonna look at some of the strategic
insights and the business case that led
into the thinking of digital
transformation at dawn then Sam is gonna
take us through together with our
partner Sukhbir here on the specifics of
this journey what the journey looks like
and how the end product will look like
what the technical technical
architecture is and towards the end
we're gonna provide you with a demo
everything goes well as planned it's
going to be basically a showcase for the
impact that the possible what we can do
with this system and at the very end
last ten minutes we're gonna take your
questions and our chief digital officer
Bob Holland is here with us today so
we're gonna invite kindly Bob to join us
with the questions so um I don't know if
you ever heard of dawn Foods it's one of
the best-kept secrets of the business
world it's a family-owned privately
owned company that's been in business
since 1920 so almost hundred years
headquartered out of Jackson Michigan
it's a bakery ingredients in bakery
products manufacturing company and what
started as a small doughnut shop in 1920
in Jackson evolved into this two billion
dollar global company with more than
four thousand people working for it
operating in more than hundred countries
with serving 40,000 customers every day
and we have more than six hundred and
fifty people who are touching these
customers on a daily basis and don't
operates in all regions of the world but
we are much bigger in North America
where we have a unique business model
which we're gonna talk about because in
North America were not only a
manufacturer but we are also a wholesale
distributor of bakery goods and bakery
supplies into the baking industry which
is vertically integrated to our
manufacturing business and what we do is
we not only manufacture our products but
we distribute these products to the
end-user with our own logistics systems
together with a bunch of other products
that are sourced from third-party
suppliers we have about 30 distribution
centers across North America and these
distribution centers these distribution
centers serve about 20,000 customers
everyday across North America what do we
sell I mean we really sell anything that
a baker needs but we can group these
things into five categories roughly we
sell non bakery foods like your nuts
raisins cream cheese we sell processed
bakery ingredients like a doughnut mix a
cake mix a brownie mix jams icings
we sell raw ingredients like sugar flour
shortening oil we sell semi finished and
finished products like your decorated
cake in a box if you shopped at Walmart
bakery products they are made by dawn
most of them so we also sell non-food
products and services like we sell
baking equipment we sell pots pans
gloves forks knives napkins you name it
anything that a baker might need we have
more than 5,000 products in our
portfolio so we operate in two different
business models across North America one
business model is the key account
business model where we take down
manufactured products like a cake mix or
an icing and we sell it directly to a
large key account like Walmart 7-eleven
McDonald's Panera you name it and in
this model because the customers are
quite large they order in very big
quantities like when Walmart orders
icing for their cakes they order like
five truckloads of icing so in this
model we ship the products directly from
our plants into the warehouses of these
large customers which is a simple
business model yet we have a second
business
model where we basically served the
small and midsize accounts these are
like your neighborhood bakeries or small
donut shops around the corner in your
neighborhood and these customers we sell
them the dome products but also the
third party sourced products and we
consolidate all of these things in our
distribution centers and delivered them
every day and their orders are by nature
smaller and more complex there's a bag
of this in it there's a pail of that in
it and we need to consolidate and make
very frequent small shipments every day
across North America so these are the
two business models by and large and
well both business models are very
relevant and important for Dawn we do
have a much bigger heritage a well
invested Network and also a competitive
sustainable competitive edge on the
small to mid-size account segment so I
mean this is the bulk of our customer
base and just like any other company
this is more profitable for us because
these small customers don't have the
negotiation power of a Walmart or a
McDonald's so this is why it's
strategically imperative for us that we
protect and grow this segment of the
market but how do we do that so as we
think about how to grow this segment of
the market we had two separate
considerations or we looked at our
business through two different lenses
one lens we used was the product
innovation lens just like any other
company we need to constantly innovate
our product portfolio so we become
relevant and we differentiate ourselves
and we do that I mean we just introduced
gluten-free concept natural colors
natural flavors different formats and
all that the problem is we have 5,000
products in the portfolio so it's very
difficult to differentiate yourself
based on product because every single
product is not significant enough to
make a difference it's a small fraction
of total sales that's why we just looked
at our business and we said well well we
have to innovate still you know we have
to bring new bakery products to the
market that's just table stakes and we
have to think about a bigger mechanism a
higher mechanism above product level
differentiate ourselves almost like a
business model innovation in innovation
where the customer experience don't
customer experience will be better if we
deliver a more enjoyable and and and
simplified don't experience for our
customers so we we thought we need to
differentiate at that level the other
lens we looked at our business which was
the undeniable factor that there's a
huge digital transformation that's
taking around us in the food service and
bakery industries which we are part of
we see online ordering coming into the
play more and more every day with
foodservice distributors Amazon they
made a public statement with their b2b
business model they said we're going to
go after foodservice and and bakery
industries and our direct manufacturing
competitors are doing a lot of digital
things to differentiate themselves so we
just looked at that and we said we don't
want we don't want to be left behind we
actually have the opportunity to be
ahead of the curve and preempt our peers
if we act fast in this digital area
because the you know digital
transformation and bakery and food
service industries are still at their
infancy so putting these two things
together the need to differentiate and
the need to stay ahead of the curve we
said we're going to invest in digital
technologies and we're gonna embark on a
digital transformation journey in
partnership with KPMG with the primary
goal to give a better customer
experience to don't customers has
differentiate ourselves so of course it
all starts with understanding our
customer who the customer is and what
they want and our customers are as I
said you know your neighborhood bakery
is the donut shops and and there's
usually a small you know venue in which
there's one decision maker the Baker and
this Baker is by definition is an artist
he or she is you know having a lot of
fun and pride and you know enjoying the
the art of baking they focus on the
passion of baking and they focus on the
quality and the taste of the food but
while it's a small establishment it's a
very complex operation at bakery so
there are a lot of other elements
so their business that they need a lot
of help and they rely on their suppliers
to provide those helps so that was one
thing we we measured that at all we
constantly look at what bakers need and
what are some of their biggest pain
points what are their biggest concerns
hopes and fears and here's our latest
research we understand that the Baker's
they know technology is going to be an
important thing in their lives it's
gonna play an important role but they
don't know how and they don't know how
to make it happen so they need help in
terms of product Baker's want to make
sure that when they put a product
portfolio an assortment in front of
their shoppers they want to make sure
that it is something that is driven from
the latest trends latest taste profiles
color profiles and the consumers will
enjoy it and they also want to access
the highest quality bakery ingredients
at the lowest price possible to make
that happen and they need supported
recipes etc labor is probably their
biggest pain point because they struggle
to find recruit trained retrain and
retain skilled labor there's huge
shortage financial as I said bakers are
artists they don't necessarily
immediately know where they make money
where they don't aura or how to
prioritize their investments so they
appreciate a lot of consulting in the
area of financial again direct marketing
targeting a certain consumer growth with
the right products and understanding
their needs and trends is not
necessarily a you know inherent skill
set that exists within bakeries and then
last but not the least regulatory and
compliance which is all about food law
the labeling requirements which is
constantly changing Baker's just want to
make sure they're first of all compliant
but they're also have access to audit
tools certifications which is required
to run their businesses so I mean while
these are very specific needs that we
have identified the overarching theme is
yes they expect products from us they
expect you know icings and cake mixes
and everything but they want a more
holistic help from us to help with their
business and with the elements of the
business that are not necess
related to baking so combining this you
know ambition to go digital and the
understanding of the customers we just
came up with this vision that says we're
going to create a digital bakery
platform which we're gonna see the demo
off and went through that bakery
platform we just want to make sure we
provide products online to our customers
but we also want to surround them with
services on a digital environment that
they're gonna be needing to run their
businesses more effectively hence
differentiate ourselves so as a working
charter this digital bakery platform
that we're going to show you today is
and you know with that we want to be an
indispensable partner with the bakers
and we want to create a sustainable
advantage through the use of technology
and data that otherwise they wouldn't
have access to and by doing that we want
to help them and we're gonna help them
achieve their goals and aspirations so
that's what we've been working out so
what does this platform look like
conceptually imagine this is a website
or an app it may take different shapes
but this is for explanation purposes at
the center of it there's gonna be a b2b
product online ordering facility where
they can basically place their orders
and get their products online while
online ordering is nothing new it's been
around for 20 years by now there's very
little of that in bakery industry so
it's still very progressive simply
because bakers are not you know digital
native people and they they you know
that the operation is very complex
product portfolio is very fragmented and
pricing is very customized per baker per
product so there's a there's an inherent
complexity which we are working on once
we get that rolling the second thing so
these are areas for bakers to go into
conceptually we want to work on we are
actually working on a b2c online
ordering facility for our Baker's the
bakers want to engage digitally with
their consumers with their shoppers they
want to make sure that they have an
online ordering facility through their
stores but
they don't know how to get it done so
we're working on a turnkey solution to
provide to the bakers so that they can
turn their own operation in it to a
digital online friendly operation and
they're gonna appreciate that we said
labor is a big issue for our Baker's we
are going to be connecting to customized
job search engines in partnership with
indeed you know monsters or someone like
zip recruiter so that the bakers are
seeing who is available and who they can
recruit they know we also will connect
them to training videos through YouTube
and we're going to connect them to
certification programs through you know
our educational institutions in terms of
marketing and innovation at dawn we have
tremendous knowledge of consumer desires
once needs trends everything and their
behavioral statistics and all that so we
want to make sure that we provide these
things to our bakers in a digestible
format that makes sense to them and
helps them get the right product
assortment and also we want to partner
with tools like Twilio where you are
gonna be helping the bakers to run
digital campaigns sales campaigns which
is gonna increase their sales and that's
that's what they want we talked about
regulatory compliance there are a lot of
companies out there that help the
companies do these things for example
track my risks comm is one of those
digital companies who are specialized in
auditing audit tools certification we
want to work with them on a bakery
specific solution and plug them to our
platform same with financial lots of
financial companies who can help us with
training measuring tools investment
prioritization tools that we can plug
onto the platform and what are the
things that we're gonna be doing is and
the side of operations think about a
neighborhood bakery receiving a large
donut order like five hundred donuts for
a college party in the middle of the
night well what they need to do is of
course make it and box it and everything
but to deliver it they usually have a
van which is sometimes out so they need
to wait for that van to come back and
the order is delayed and all that
sted we want to connect them to a last
mile delivery service like post mates
curbside so they can they don't need
that van anymore maybe they can just
deliver their product through those
services by doing those things they're
gonna be able to look at their business
and their assets very differently and we
can go on and on and be as creative as
we want with these things but the
central idea here is to provide our
customers with the online ordering
facility and their high quality products
but also surround them with these
digital services or the platform that
will help them with their broader
business and that's how we are planning
to differentiate ourselves from those
competitors who are just selling
traditional products today with that I'm
gonna hand it off to Sam thanks for her
I've heard the story so many times and
it's just incredible that here's a
hundred-year-old company what would be
hundred years next year right that's
gone through so many transformations
this is the fourth or fifth
transformation if I remember one of the
story lines that you have did you talk
about the first one actually being you
know when we had the Great Depression
right they the company reinvented itself
and is going through so many
transformation so this is a this is a
company that actually worked through
quite a bit of change and is now ready
for the next frontier so what I want to
sort of take you through is Sarah talked
about how entrenched the entire value
proposition is with regards to talking
to the customers and frankly to the
customers customers which are consumers
like you and I and really building out
how do you actually relate to them how
do you engage with them how do you
create that stickiness but I want to
unpack that conceptual view the value
proposition view and the conceptual view
this is the previous slide that he that
serhat showed and build on it and talk
about what does the logical model look
like to you and you unpack that and when
you unpack that what does the physical
model look like which is the technical
elements needed to make this a reality
it's great to talk about business
agility but since it's so entrenched in
sort of linking business and Technology
together
making business technology and digital
capabilities together it's kind of
incredible that you had to bring all
this together to actually deliver a
value proposition so I want to sort of
uncover that and then when we when we
get to the end of the presentation
Sukhbir will come up here and do a quick
demo of our of where we see this going
look before I get into it I want to talk
about this journey a little bit because
the journey that we started together
about eight nine months ago it didn't
sort of happen you know there's an app
of the fingers there was a lot of
interaction there was a lot of working
with sir hatt's
Don leadership team the board bob steams
the Bob's obviously part of the
leadership team but really getting
everybody to understand what is the
value here why should you make this
pivot and why is it important it didn't
happen the snap of fingers Azeroth will
definitely tell you so I want to sort of
walk through how do we actually go to
the process and what kind of an approach
did we use to help people think through
it right now I'm gonna spend too much
time on it but it is it is what we think
of us as our transformation framework
this is business led digital
transformation I want to be very clear
and the journey is what we what we
really believe it because this is not
gonna happen
in one year two years it actually takes
a little bit of time and more
importantly is needs to be sustainable
you can't just expect that this will
happen in two years and then you're done
it's not an initiative it's a pivot for
the whole firm and the whole company
we call it the connected enterprise and
really the connected Enterprise has
several key elements to it and I'm going
to go through all of it I'm just going
to spend about three or four minutes
going through the the top-line
capabilities if you may the first
serhat spent a lot of time talking about
it which is the fact that the customer
agenda is actually ready for disruption
everything that we talked about is
customer centric is outside in the
surveys that the serhat talked about the
interactions with the customers and the
cuss and in this case the artisanal
bakers the Walmarts of the world and
their consumers
was very important to inform what the
strategy needs to look like right so
once we had that in place really started
to take a look at what kind of
experiences do we need to create in
order to enable that today and down the
road so this notion of creating
experience
and customer experiences that are going
to really effectively enable the
strategy that was created was an
extremely important part of it and oh by
the way we were not looking at just
products and services that Don provided
we opened up the aperture to say what
does a customer really want from us and
we created this this this notion that we
said was more important for you to
understand what experiences the customer
wants not what experiences you could
provide still an outside-in perspective
and then translating that in terms of
organizational capabilities to deliver
our number one and number two right how
do you deliver a profitable growth how
do you deliver this from an
organizational capability because nobody
else is going to do it you have to do it
and you have to transform your
organization to do that when you looked
at all of this and you pivot into what
capabilities are necessary how do you
break down these silos that we're
normally used to whether it's you know
supply chain Tony does this or you know
your customer service stream only does
this right how do you break down these
barriers between front middle and back
office and how do you create an
environment that allows transformation
to happen more naturally that was really
what we were jointly working on together
and so there are eight capabilities that
we believe and this is all based on
research by the way that we've done over
the last three years
not just from talking to customers but
working with external parties who have
actually thought through what these
capabilities need to be and they've done
service for us we've done research we've
really entrenched that research in terms
of outcomes and constantly refined it
I'm not going to go through these eight
capability it's just gonna point out a
couple three of them right the first one
is kind of obvious I think a lot of us
are here because we believe that
insights driven strategies and actions
are core to the way a digital or
business would behave in a digital world
right and what's interesting is that one
of the service KPMG does on an annual
basis with CEOs across the globe we
found that while everybody sort of
believes that this is their strategy
seventy eight percent of CEOs actually
don't use data-driven insights to inform
their decisions they still go with their
gut I'm not suggesting that gut is not
important for a CEO in particular but
this is something that
that we've sort of we are learning and
we're trying to inform everybody but
this we believe is core to one and one
of the capabilities required for our
transformation
Sahra is not one of those CEOs by the
way but the second one of course Sarah
talked about which is the innovation on
products and services not only
innovation of existing products that you
sell to your customers but also digital
twins that you want that you want to
sell or enhance your existing products
with experience sensor City that's
something that is talked about a lot
where your customers really are the
center of your universe and you want to
deliver an experience not just a product
for them right and this is not just for
the customer but also your employees so
that they're serving customers more
effectively and that's extremely
important as well
seamless commerce and seamless
interactions this is about omni-channel
capabilities so that if you start a
transaction or if you start an inquiry
or you start a conversation or one
channel which could be digital that you
don't lose track of it you don't lose
track of it when somebody walks in the
store or walks up to your your your
sales agent or whoever it might be the
piece that is is a challenge as you
start to unfold all these capabilities
is the response of operations and supply
chain supply chain is sort of making a
move and we believe this is an important
move from being make centric and cost
centric to be customer centric and
commercially oriented right sort of
moving upstream so that you're not just
thinking of yourself as I got to deliver
the best product create the best product
or those cheapest price and so we can go
on and on through this it suffice it to
say that we believe obviously the
alignment of people talent whether it's
growing talent internally changing the
way people think or externally hiring
talent is very important and finally a
digital enable architecture which we
will talk about in a little bit more
detail so I'm not going to delve it it
delve into details there sir had already
talked about the importance of the
partner ecosystem and the fact that you
want to welcome partners and what's what
very refreshing about this is none of
this is sort of behind some firewall
sitting in so hard and Bob go out and
talk to their customers talk to their
partners are very open about what they
want to do which is sort of what's our
heart calls the open source world of
businesses right you want to sort of
share as much as you can so that you're
inviting people into your ecosystem and
you're creating possibilities that you
never knew power
right and so that's something that we
want to our creating opportunities that
you never knew possible so one of the
things I'll end with is that as we
started to unpack this more and more we
found that as we talked about it and
began to monitor companies that were
using this companies that use this kind
of a framework not exactly the framework
but really invested in those
capabilities were twice as likely to
succeed in their transformation efforts
and this is something that whether you
believe in exactly all those
capabilities or you want to modify some
of this this is directionally where we
believe companies will need to go in
order to survive and thrive in the
digital age
and this is where when sorrowed open we
really are trying to link those two
together and saying there is no business
strategy and digital strategy it's one
in the same thing and you have to
understand how they work together and
how you would sustain them together so
with that said and as a backdrop for how
we actually went through this journey I
want to sort of transition a little bit
into where we left off with our story
and so how talking about what is Dawn
looks like as a platform company
conceptually these are the products
services areas categories that we
believe is important down Don believes
very important for the future proofing
the business at the heart of this of
course is all the data that you're going
to collect this is a fairly seasonal
business Baker's have to react there
obviously there's a lot of bakery
business all throughout the year but
when they get into Thanksgiving or now
coming up with Easter there's a big
spike when are they actually looking for
labor what kind of Labor they're looking
for how often did they look for that
labor what can they pay for you know
what kind of you know you are collecting
that data even if you anonymize it it's
very powerful data and so each one of
these bubbles or clouds that you look at
creates and puts out so much data that
we believe that is actually how we're
going to keep this a sustainable
competitive edge for Don and for their
Baker's so let's sort of unpack and go
from a conceptual view into a more of a
logical view and then into a technology
view so if you look at this a little
differently in order for us to be able
to create what we think of as a
plug-and-play architecture there are two
fundamental l
that are necessary even before you get
down to collecting the data right to be
able to create these business services
that's our hot talked about whether it's
connecting up it indeed or a gig economy
a provider of resources or whoever you
have there's two things that we wanted
to sort of ensure that we do the first
one was working together with it with
the with the don team said it needs to
be a micro services based architecture
whether you're building your own you're
plugging something in you essentially
need the ability to plug into a chassis
and that micro services architecture has
to enable that right the second piece is
that using AP is that are readily
available is an excellent way to
accelerate and frankly not only
accelerate but also run tests and learn
cycles and we're doing some of that and
exploring that as we go along when we go
into the details we'll talk about some
of that but all of this whatever the
area is are there Bob talked about in
the pre-op sorry sir how talked about in
the previous slide with operations
marketing technology knowledge etc what
we believe is that you would need these
to plug in to a technology backbone that
you would what we're calling the core
business platform for Don or Don core
business platform so what does that look
like today that is built on a Google GCP
backbone that is think of that is the
chassis that chassis is where everything
is going to plug into and the chassis
obviously has core capabilities which
we'll talk about in a second but it also
has business solutions we don't think of
YouTube as a business solution we just
think of it as a cool place to watch
videos possibly but Don has already
started the process of creating a Don
Channel right somebody knows what does
it look like when you're creating a very
specific product or or a end product for
your for your customer and what do you
need to in order to be able to create
that because this is an art for them
this is their passion they want to learn
about new techniques for frosting or to
create a new kind of a cake or what's
what's coming up in the in the food
services industry that is relevant to
them so when we look at this we are
actually looking at plugging in things
that are fairly native to what Google
already does and we're calling those
Google
the solutions right it's still part of
Google cloud but it's a business
solution that is provided
it could be AdWords could be expressed
shopping lists it could be
recommendations API that we're going to
use right but there are things that you
have to always create by yourself you
know one of them is the commerce engine
we do believe that in order to achieve
the goals that that service you talked
about you are going to need to transact
fundamentally well that's not native in
the Google cloud yep at least but we
will be using a commerce engine that we
will plug and play from elsewhere we
will be creating our own customer
service transformation interaction
models we will be creating things that
are specific to what Don needs curated
by drawn created by Don but they will
all ultimately plug into the same
chassis and we believe that's extremely
important for us when you sort of unpack
this a little bit more what we're seeing
is that we're going to use I mean this
is all this is not a technical deep tie
presentation but I'm going to do the
best I can to sort of cover the top
elements right you are going to have a
server let's computing architecture you
are going to have an elastic cloud you
are going to have all those things that
are normal expected container engines
whatever you want to call it right you
are going to do all of that and that's
sort of the top line item you are going
to use a big queries you're going to do
all of that but there are elements that
you need in order to deliver this
business agility which will only come
from really thinking about your ability
to not only subscribe to api's but also
publish api's right so as much as you're
subscribing to an API and we'll talk
about that in a second we're also going
to publish API so that other people
might use maybe it's the organizer of
this event that need you know I don't
know how many doughnuts we had in the
morning maybe we don't have any
doughnuts but maybe they need 2,000
doughnuts a day right they could
subscribe to this and find a way to
engage with artisanal bakers to deliver
those 2,000 dollars a day in the morning
right so when we look at the enabling
technologies and what it takes to be
able to really unpack this there are two
elements to it the first is the ability
to sort of have a conversational and
interface and that's what we're using
dialogue flow for so I'm going to
literally just not talk about the top
row there because I think we've already
have
sessions that cover those we're gonna
talk about the business elements of this
the first one is dialogue flow and we'll
talk a little bit more butter but
dialogue flow is essentially the
interaction engine for conversational
commerce extremely powerful if you don't
know if about it I would recommend you
you you you learn more about it because
it really brings across the notion that
whether you're interacting with a
customer using Google home or whether
you're using your mobile phone or
whether you're using some other element
that you don't know about today it will
be extremely powerful
the second that we found very valuable
is the ability to store session data
because your performance of your
conversation is important and that
speech the text the text to speech kind
of elements are important you will need
to have a caching capability and we are
using firebase for that cloud
communications we use Twilio to be able
to start use using the ability to alert
people quickly give them informed and if
you don't know tell you I would
recommend you get to know them now
you're gonna get into I'm going to talk
about the commerce engine next which is
commerce tools
it's a ground-up microservices
architecture based commerce engine right
we found it to be extremely powerful
easy to plug-and-play easy to get off
the ground and really curate your
overall interactive experience and
commerce tools is is is one of and we
believe one of the what are the two
vendors are that that's doing a great
amount of work around how do you
actually plug into more of a cloud-based
native micro services architecture
now this interesting part that I left
off in Biddle is actually one the
elements where we believe we're going to
generate a lot of business interest this
is what we think of as one aspect of our
fulfillment engine now one of the one of
the things that came out and and we're
obviously learning from the market and
there's a huge test and learn cycle that
works pretty quickly is that last mile
delivery for fulfillment is important
the example that uses serhat you know I
got a deliver you know 500 cupcakes now
I need ingredients tomorrow how are you
going to get it to me you can either use
Don's logistics network
to be able to deliver it which is not
done meant for last mile delivery or you
can engage by plugging and playing a
post mates or somebody else to be able
to do it right and what we're saying is
eventually we expect that these
partnerships whether it's supposed to
mate or whether it's somebody else
curbside what-have-you you're going to
start using these these to be able to
actually deliver products on the last
mile and we're going to see that when we
get to the demo
all right we've actually plugged that in
what we also found is that it's not a
one-size-fits-all you could use post
mates in New York you could use curbside
in Miami you could use your own network
in in Chicago you could whatever you
want ultimately you have the ability to
plug in business api's business services
and rapidly get it off the ground in
terms of of course you know when you're
looking at these business api is it's
kind of complicated because there are a
lot of operational factors but what used
to be the longest pole in the tent which
is connect up the whole infrastructure
from post meets connect up there's make
sure it works we got it done in a week
at least the the first shot at it we got
it done in a week and that was actually
a big revelation for us because it is
about the speed of business this is
about the clock speed of business and if
technology doesn't support that we've
got a big problem and this is really
what it's meant to do is to accelerate
that process for those of you sort of
interested in the architecture diagram
within disappoint so we do have the more
complex ones that I've seen it's
actually a very simple one compared to
where we are going to be but this is
setting up the demo a little bit just to
give you a flavor for I'm not gonna
steal subpage thunder here but really
what I want to communicate here is the
fact that we have separate out the
modalities of interaction from the api's
API is is actually where you know in
some sense the magic happens and and you
can look at it as those of you are
technologists and say of plugging in the
API is extremely important the
resiliency of the API the the
performance of the of the service itself
etcetera etcetera etcetera but we're
seeing that a lot of the magic is
beginning to happen and will happen
continue to happen on the front end
because of the
vices that are proliferating businesses
we foresee a situation where there could
be a Google device sitting at every
artisanal Baker and they're going to
actually use the device to interact with
Don not sort of get on a phone or do
something else we believe that that is
extremely important for the future of
this platform that is being created and
and should be we'll go through why we
believe that's the case of an experience
perspective speaking about the connected
enterprise story and how important
experiences are a part of it for the
purposes of our conversation today one
of the things I want to point out is the
entire API gateway I shouldn't say the
entire piece let me clarify the API
gateway is based on Apogee now not every
API is available to our Apogee so
sometimes you have to go directly to the
to the provider to the service provider
and get the API and connect to them
commerce tools is an example of that
it's not available at least when we
started off it wasn't available as a
part of Apogee but post meets this and
we accelerated our process because we
used Apogee to connect the back-end so
we are obviously this is a this is a
aboard
it's a drill-down off the actual
architecture that we have there's a
bigger architecture that brings in a lot
of the machine learning capabilities the
data capabilities that are extremely
important for the growth of this so with
that I'm gonna hand it over to Sapir to
actually go through the demo and then
we'll have about 78 minutes for a Q&A at
the end of this thanks Sam so before we
begin is there a clicker there thank you
it's really important to understand
first the actual experience that we're
looking to enhance for a lot of these
Baker's so throughout this journey what
we've done is we've got gone and visited
a lot of these bakeries across the
country and we've you know we spent the
day with them to understand what their
current experience really is what we
found is a lot of them you know they
they handle every aspect of their
business it's not only honing their
craft and their art but it's also really
effectively running their business so
they're in the back you know they're
actually the ones in the kitchens
creating the goods
they are then you know moving over
washing up and going over to their
laptops and you know calling up vendors
to see tracking orders bill payments and
then also handling customer service
they're also you know looking up new
recipes looking on social media they're
trying to find out you know how do I get
inspired to build what I love doing so
with that in mind we fed it created a
demo to see if how do we handle and
enhance this experience for them so
they're not kind of running around
everywhere and it really creates almost
a seamless interaction with them so with
that in mind if we could transition to
the demo screen so there are many
mediums you could use to centrally
interact with this platform here which
we are calling Baker Assist for this
situation we've used the Google
assistant mobile app and so just to
engage with it you know one would just
have to start off by saying talk to
Baker assist all right here's the test
version of Baker Assist
hi I'm Baker Assist have a question
about ingredients or baking techniques
I'm here to answer you may also choose
to subscribe to Baker alerts to receive
upcoming instructional videos by asking
alert me on new tips that sounds pretty
cool so I think I'm going to ask to be
alerted alert me on new tips okay I'll
start alerting you I noticed that the
NYC autumn Food Festival is trending on
social media and will take place near
your location within the next several
days some type of pumpkin dessert might
be great for this event so you see here
they're pairing location they're able to
do the research and kind of provide all
that information right to you at your
fingertips I mean this sounds really
neat and it's right near me pumpkin
desserts during autumn was always great
so I'm thinking a pumpkin dessert maybe
I want to learn how to make pumpkin
doughnuts show me a video on how to
make pumpkin doughnuts here's the
instructional video for making pumpkin
doughnut perfect so I can access this
hey guys it's corn sweet world and today
we're making these pumpkin doughnuts
whatever you see if it's called YouTube
and figured out a repository of videos
that we have to be inspired and terminus
of how to make new Goods and now I want
to know a little bit more detail
regarding these pumpkin doughnuts I've
just learned to make show me the
ingredients for the pumpkin doughnut
recipe here are the ingredients for
pumpkin doughnut and so I take a look at
these ingredients and I see one of the
ingredients here is whole wheat flour
now you know as sûreté mentioned a lot
of these bakers they're really
entrenched in their communities and I
know my community and I know that they
you know they're very health conscious
so maybe I want gluten-free flour
instead are there gluten free
substitutes for wheat flour sure here
are a list of wheat flour substitutes
that are gluten free almond flour
buckwheat flour amaranth flour teff
flour brown rice flour brown rice flour
seems pretty cool so add 5 kg of brown
rice flour to my cart great 5 kilograms
of brown rice flour as successfully
added to cart add the pumpkin donut
recipe to my cart
grate the pumpkin doughnuts products are
added to cart so instead of adding each
and item I can add the entire block of
items view my cart here are your cart
details looks pretty good place order
great your order has been placed
successfully your order will arrive in
three to four business days however it
looks like the NYC autumn
food festival is only two days away
would you like to opt for fast delivery
well that's a good thing they told me
that so of course I want fast delivery
yes you have opted for expedited
delivery great so now as the Baker I can
go in take a look at where my order is
and you know based on based out of New
York and I can see that you know my
order is waiting to be accepted right
now and will be delivered fairly soon
and I can track it I can go away and you
know handle the rest of my business and
whenever I feel like checking up my
order and I I can do that as well as I
know I'll be alerted on the status of my
order as the day goes on
[Music]